we're gonna get started
first question tim reynolds
hey jimmy uh boring night
good morning night good night um
you've been on well first off you being
the soccer fan that you
are does it sort of feel like a sort of
kind of like a walk-off pk
for you at all in that moment i guess so
don't get me hyped up making me think
that i'm a footballer that's out for my
problem but
as long as we win i wish i could kick it
in there and uh
and say that that's how i want it but
we'll take a dub however we can get it
how frustrating though was the last 20
seconds
so much went wrong and to be in that
situation were you guys frustrated at
all or did you just believe you're gonna
find a way
it's part of the game we're gonna find a
way um if the game did happen to go into
overtime
we're still gonna win that game we're
confident
um you know they they're a hell of a
team though i will tell you that
but i i like our chances
jimmy please take us through the uh the
last possession what was called in the
huddle
what happened when you got the ball is
it a matter of you want to at least make
sure
time right now for overtime take us
through that and please let us know
your emotions when it said zeros on the
clock and they went to the table to see
if there was time
when the foul was called um it was uh it
was iso
gorham made a hell of a pass on inbound
and then just wait for the clock to
go out step back jumper and i got fouled
pushed me in the back
can't deny that um and then i
i knew i had to make one out of two so
you know ended up i think i made both of
them
and we win okay the first one though
sort of rims out and then rims back in
watching
and what do you think going forward i
mean a lot of people say it was a shaky
finish and a lot of other people say
you're up 2-0 against the eastern
conference regular season champs
i said it time and time again we truly
do not care what other people say
um because the same people that think oh
yada yada yada
will be the same ones and say something
when something doesn't go our way so
we stay focused on what we can we
control what we can
and we're not looking at it like we're
up to zero just zero zero
we're going home and um we're we're
expecting to win the next one
anthony chang hey jimmy uh
last game he scored 40 points today you
know he took eight shots scored 13. was
it a matter of them did they play you
differently or was it a matter of just
guys getting in rhythm
and you feeding them no um
i think i told y'all after the last game
anybody can do that for us anybody can
score points tonight
gorham tyler j bam um dj came in and hit
some big buckets
uh we got a team full of guys that
aren't scared to take and make shots
um i love this group i don't need to be
a 40 point per night score
that's not my role here my role is to
impact winning
and um i think i did that on both sides
of the ball tonight
tim attempts i mean what was going
through your mind when you got trapped
in the corner there
and uh ended up resulting in that
turnover i think we're like
10 or 15 seconds left tried to shoot it
in their basket obviously
i almost made it um i don't know why i
threw the ball so high
like gorham could jump that high and
grab it but uh
i saw goran and i was thinking you know
throw it gordon's way
actually it's a terrible iq play you
should never throw the ball
towards the other team's basket i had a
lapse of judgment
and if you i mean you've played a lot of
games a lot of playoff games you ever
been anything
like that that last minute or so of that
game with all the stuff that happened
uh no i have not but uh you never know
what to expect in the playoffs
um but we we gotta win out of it no
matter what happens three free throws
for them
two for those for us we we got a w in
that column
taylor rooks did we go away from the
game just a bit when you were walking
off the court i saw you look at pat
riley and you said you're healthy so you
don't have to worry about giving you a
heart attack
um but you guys seem to have such good
camaraderie there's always some moments
between you guys
describe that relationship because i
don't know if most players have that
with
their execs uh that's
that's the godfather man that's the og
um a huge reason why i'm here
obviously but uh i say it time and time
again
he wanted me here and that's the best
feeling to know that
you're wanted in an organization and
they want you as a player they want what
you can bring to the table
you know he has so much trust and belief
in my abilities
and just trickles down the line i'm
thankful for him spo
all of these knuckleheads i get to hoop
with it's a blessing being here miami
mike coogno hey jimmy you want to go
back to free throws for a second i
noticed something i don't think i've
seen you do this before you walked over
to the net
and you kind of grabbed the net and
maybe i don't know if you were composing
yourself
is that something you were trying to do
there to kind of relax
knowing the the situation coming up
i told you i didn't even notice that i
didn't i was just
um walking out there tell the truth i
didn't realize that people weren't going
to be on the
side of the lane so i just walked up
there tugged on that and went back to
the
there was nothing to it i don't even
know why i did it i guess it worked
maybe i should do that every game
nick friedel jimmy in a normal world now
you would go back home and have the next
couple games
in miami what do you have to say
to everybody to maintain the mental
focus
that you guys have had now since you've
been in there
nothing nothing i don't have to say they
know
um it's it's a known thing that you
can't relax you can't get comfortable
they're too good of a team and they do
so many things well that we have to
continually get better
because i don't think we played our best
type of basketball tonight we will study
the film
we'll practice we will work on that
we'll come back even better than we were
tonight
west lambie all right jimmy um can you
just go back in terms of
obviously the uh just that atmosphere of
shooting those walk-off free throws in
terms of like you mentioned no one being
um on either side of the lane and then
obviously um
you were uh and obviously also like uh
basically uh no fans you know to even
maybe hear your atmosphere
what are your thoughts on that uh i mean
i
i guess there's no fans on any free
throws yeah
so it's kind of the same it's just
different whenever
um like nobody's on line at the end of
the game
but you step up and you make one and
that's that's the ball game so i
felt like i did that did my job in that
part of it but it was
different but it's still a free shot
david from la gazzetta dello sport italy
hey jimmy you guys finished with seven
players in double figures you
mentioned this how deep is your team but
uh what do you think about how many
weapons you guys have and
how can you guys use it at the best
i've said it time and time again we have
so many guys that do so many things
well and um whenever you have that you
can't can on just one guy
we got so many guys that are constantly
working on their game they get to pick
and choose our spots
you know documentation for us bam what's
you
for us tyler goran
um but it feels good to know that
these guys are comfortable in any point
in the game
and last question manny navarro
i asked gore on the same question um you
know outside of the crazy finish tonight
you guys were pretty much in control of
this game i don't think they had the
lead very much at all
and obviously you're up to nothing in
the series does it all feel like you're
dictating you guys are basically doing
everything you want in this series so
far
uh i wouldn't say everything we've come
out slow
um these first two games in the sense
that they've been comfortable
we've been fouling way too many jump
shooters you know we talk about that
but um being up 2-0 is a great thing but
we just cannot relax we cannot get
comfortable
and um moving forward we're going to be
better
thank you jimmy appreciate your time
tonight